good morning good afternoon good evening
depending on where you are joining us
from welcome to simply learn we are
honored to have you join us today for
how recommendations system works on
Amazon and Netflix with your host Simon
Nava solely my name is Richard and after
the center will be mostly in the
background helping Simon so that
everything runs smoothly smooth how
recommendation systems work on Amazon
and Netflix and they certainly got me I
know the head said I'm working when I
went on there and purchased it I
actually bought two of them I'm very
happy about it
they got twice the business if you do
not know Simon Simon is a self-motivated
result orientated and high achieving
professional with years of hands-on a
leadership experience developing
award-winning business intelligence
performance measurement and analytics
solutions 10 plus years of experience
teaching certificate courses to
statistics and BI tools best
specializing in eLearning Simon has a
master's in biostatistics from the
University of Western Ontario along with
certifications and everything data and
big data analytics Simon is passionate
about teaching data science and has a
number of journal publications in
preventive medicine analytics for those
who aren't familiar with this former
webinar I want to introduce you to your
dashboard if everyone could locate the
dashboard and then locate the question
module if it has auto collapse click on
the red arrow and then find the question
part on there and go ahead and message
hello just say hi to Simon let's just
know let him know you're excited to be
here and it also lets us know that our
sound system is working and I see we
have Alejandra already said hi earlier
deposits that you for being here
Sam Bob cigar we have a lot of people
Kumar and I apologize right off the bat
if I get your name mispronounced I have
a long ways a lot of learning to go to
get the names right this question module
is your best friend assignments going
through the presentation go ahead and
type your questions in here because we
do have a lot of people on
save those questions for the last 15
minutes and we'll do a question and
answer period at the last 15 minutes of
the session and get to as many of those
as we can if you hear something awesome
brilliant interesting insightful and you
want to share it in your social channels
whatever your social channels are
Facebook Linkedin tweet you can use a
hashtag SL webinars that way people can
find it and you'll make them wish they
were here go ahead sit back and relax
have a cup of coffee tea or if it's
evening where you're at maybe a glass of
wine and enjoy you didn't come here to
listen to me it's an honor for me to
hand this over to Simon for how
recommendation system works on Amazon
and Netflix thank you and happy learning
we look forward to seeing you in our
classrooms Thank You Simon for being
here with us today thank you sir I
really appreciate your kind words on
great introduction I hope everyone is
good sorry about a couple of minutes of
delay because of technical issue that we
had but I try to make that up so
hopefully this webinar could be helpful
and would be helpful for you guys in
terms of bring bringing information that
you learn in data science class and see
cases studies so without further ado
let's start this session as we should
mentioned my name is Simon I have years
of experience working in business
analytics and teaching data science
predictive analytics and statistics and
education was hit by statistics from
different from in whichever Center
Ontario objective of this webinar is to
learn how to leverage predictive
analytics and big data to
recommendations system to enhance
customers experience and boost sales we
will first learn a little bit about
predictive analytics and recommendation
system so hopefully you would have a
general idea of what recommendations
are then we will go to a couple of cases
studies at Amazon and insults which are
pioneer and leading organization in
terms of implementing recommendation
system into their business and then
quickly rule review lessons learned from
these two cases studies recommendations
is that let's go through some
definitions and so recommendation system
is an extensive class of web
applications that involve predicting
user responses to options so there is
this prediction component into it and
also it will provide responses or
options that would match that prediction
recommendation systems help users
discover content based on their unique
needs and preferences so it's all about
customization and making it tailored to
a person's needs and preferences for
example in terms of an article in an
online newspaper you may be interested
in seeing your local news first a
recommendation system would enable that
online newspaper to provide local news
to you first so once you go to their
home page you would be able to see if
you're interested you will see your
local needles first or if you wouldn't
it be great if if you're searching for
cars and for some reason you search
online and then recommendations it's a
quick cut off and then whenever you go
to sites instead of advertisement for I
don't know shampoo you will see
advertisement for economy car that is
it's sort of advertisement that is
customized to your needs and it's
relevant to your needs or in terms of
offering customers things that they
might like to buy let's say if you're
interested in buying electronic products
wouldn't it be nice if you go to Amazon
then in
stead of searching browsing and spending
time to create to that electronic
product catalog you will see it right up
on front page so this is this is what
recommendation systems would do I
recommend there's recommender system and
recommendation system or engine these
are terms that are used interchangeably
learns from a customer so this is a very
important component and recommend so
based on that learning it would predict
needs and it would categorize classify a
customer and recommends products or
information that he or she will find
most valuable in stores places like
Amazon ecommerce we will see that
recommendation systems for example
recommend products in terms of product
is discovery in terms of loyalty
programs in terms of email campaigns
bills and mailers and etc so a lot of
use cases that recommendation systems
can of defensives recommender system is
what businesses need in many many ways
and some studies by a marketer and
research companies that have some uses
from research companies have found that
it can bring up to 30% additional
revenue to businesses and that's why
business community really recognize that
78% of business community think that
analytic capabilities to understand
customer behavior is important or 78
percent think that developing content
and experience either Centuri customer
journey is very important and 3/4 of the
business community think that delivering
relevant personalized customer
experiences is important so huge demand
and and a lot of growing demand as well
one of the
places that recommendation systems are
useful is in marketing and advertisement
enables marketers to prioritize their
spend in terms of what to provide
customers with and enable them to
understand how consumers behave it's a
huge industry so for those who know
recommendation systems lot of
opportunities a lot of job opportunities
it's a two hundred and sixty billion
dollar by twenty two in industry so as
you can imagine these internet
advertisement is a huge huge industry
and a recommendation system is an
important part of it and ninety four
percent of companies agree that
personalization is critical to current
and future success so just imagine two
hundred and sixty billion industry we
need people that would develop them
recommendation systems just look at this
figure below twenty seven percent of
Americans think that retailers don't
recognize them on different devices
forty five percent I think that digital
ads that promote products that they
purchase not what they looking to buy
Alex it really big figures that forty
nine percent of people said that digital
ads that are irrelevant to what I'm
interested in buying
so if advertisement industry and
marketing industry could reduce these
bad values just imagine that how would
and how sucks how would it be and how
successful they would be so huge demand
in marketing and advertising also in
different sectors like e-commerce Amazon
is an example that will go through a
video on demand is for examinee other
video the main industry that I use
recommendations you send to manage
customers to movies based on their
tastes
and social media our customers can view
what people with similar tastes viewed
and internet musica stations that
similar to video on-demand they can
match people with their music that they
like recommendation systems are a type
of filter to narrow down a list of
available options so if you could really
really simplify that recommendation
system is a filter that sits in between
items and people and it would filter
items based on user profile so it's a
type of filtering if we could simplify
that and if you're wondering about
what's the difference between a search
engine and a recommendation is that
recommendation is the voice results
searching in searching people goes for
example to Google and search for items
and then they have to browse and find
things but a recommendation system can
do the job can predict and identify a
person's taste and preferences and then
recommend those ideas to the person so
that's how you can distinguish between
searching versus recommending three
popular methods of recommendations are
three types of recommendations we have
collaborative filtering we have
content-based filtering and we have
hybrid of these two so these are just
broad types of recommendations in
collaborator 14 the first one it's based
on interest of a community of users so a
group of users let's say a group of
people who live in New York they are 20
to 25 years old and they their
preferences are similar in compared to a
group of people who are 40 to 45 years
old and they
in Mexico City so that's what we mean by
interest of the community of users
content basically the second one is
based on similar content so it's as its
name implies it's based on items it's
not based on people and we have some
hybrid versions so I will go to a little
bit more in detail about the first two
and and I will show you like that how
Amazon uses a hybrid version of these
filtering methods so collaborative
filtering collaborating filtering this
method finds a subset of users who have
similar tastes and preferences and how
they would do that in terms of
methodology would be to cross Turing in
classification and various data
modelling for those of you guys who have
taken data science you know we have we
have gone through some examples of
classifying people and identifying and
grouping them together based on
commonalities that they share basic
assumptions of collaborative filtering
is that users with similar interests
have common preferences and sufficiently
large number of user preferences are
available main approach is main
approaches are either user based or IBM
base so user based as this example would
show that for example Tom and Dick are
common in terms of identity they're both
happy on purchasing purchasing item by
item it could be a an Apple computer
either based is for example Jane when
she bought item a headphone for iPhone
and item D which is iPhone itself so she
was happy when she bought about them
both so that's that's the difference
between user based and item based
collaborative filtering
user based collaborative filtering use
user item rating matrix it's shown in
the table below it make user to use a
correlation for example in this example
user 3 so users are enrolled and items
are in column the user 3 and user a
which is a reference person have shared
interest in terms of item 1 item 2 and
item 4 so make user to use a correlation
fund highly correlated users recommend
items preferred by those users so there
is a star on top of this page right top
part and it says Pearson correlation and
prediction function for those of you
again who are engaging who enroll in a
data science course with art you know
that we go to these Pearson correlation
and correlation analysis we go to
examples of how to do that and you see
that how big companies on how
recommendation system use those
techniques in terms of recommending
things so these are are the things that
I'm trying to link the everyday world
and case use of these methods in
recommendation system to what we learn
in data science course in terms of
advantages of these collaborative
filtering is that no knowledge about
identity so it's all about users it's
about what they preferred so they don't
for example if it is Amazon they don't
need to know futures of good let's go
back to that example of iPhone and
earphone for our case protection case
for iPhone so there is no need for the
recommendation system to analyze
features of those products it's just
based on people who bought these these
two products and they're happy and there
are some problems so the problems about
this particular requires filtering is
that new users
there is not enough information about
new users right because if a person is
new to ecommerce site the site doesn't
know anything about that person so it
would be hard and so that that's one
issue I knew I then call the start
problem is that when a new item comes
and there is no prior evidence of in
terms of how happy people are in terms
of buying that idea with another idea
that is the problem of cold and starting
with the item itself there is another
issue with as Varsity problem and that
is that there are many items to be
recommended that user rating matrix is
as farce and it's hard to find the users
who have rated the same items so what
this means it means that for example
Amazon we have millions and millions of
products that are available and for some
items because it's it's so huge some
items are not captured properly because
because there is because it's like
people have different preferences and
sometimes you cannot find enough number
of people who are happy about a range of
items and we have popularity voice and
that's is that these filtering tend to
recommend only popular items so for
example if a new iPhone is on the market
and it's very popular that would come up
a lot in this correlational analysis
behind the scene and that's why as a
biased recommendation gene tends to
offer that a lot so these are pros and
cons of these type of filtering now just
a reminder that VR is still in
collaborative filtering and this is item
based collaborative filter so if you go
back user base so we are still on
collaborating so thing we had user base
and we had identities now this is item
base so this is
user user item rating metrics make item
to item correlation again for those of
you who taken or will be taking data
science you will see these what we mean
by correlation we will do a lot of these
correlational analysis and of course
it's based on finding items that are
highly correlated so for example in
terms of user one you will see that user
one but item for item three and item
item sorry user one by item four
animator five and this is the same as
user three and user for so
recommendation system based on this
pattern of choosing would know that
similar users would tend to buy item for
an item five together that's why for
example if item four is I don't know and
a Microsoft computer and item 5 is a
protection case for that computer or
whatever then based on similarity of
these users recommendations that would
recommend that particular item there are
some pros and cons some advantages and
disadvantages about this item based
collaborative filtering advantages would
be no knowledge about any future needed
similar tool if we respond better
scalability because correlations are
between limited number of items instead
of very large number of users and
reducing the sparsity problem new user
called the start problem again that
would be a problem the new item called
the sub problem and these are the issues
that Amazon and eBay could have that's
why they're using a number of different
filtering approaches now
second type of filtering is
content-based fitting so the previous
one is collaborative filtering just a
reminder this is content-based filtering
this is based on the idea it's not about
person so this this type of filtering
would ignore people it would just focus
on items there are two approaches either
recommend items similar to those a user
has like browse or purchase purchase in
the past or recommendations are based on
the content of Islands rather than on
other users opinion so an example is
here done in the figure you see that if
a person had some purchases in the past
a person is a really a movie fan and
purchased a lot of movies so
recommendation system would go and
search the person's past history and
will see that there is a correlation
between movies that this person bought
and these are sci-fi movies right so
based on that and this person could have
bought some drama movies as well but
recommendation system can true
correlation analysis can see that there
is a correlation among sci-fi movies so
that's why the recommendation for this
person would be a another sci-fi movie
so it's about items in terms of user
profile and until for how this content
based filtering is is that it creates
user profile to describe the type of
items that user prefer so what we see in
that grey box is a user profile right it
would show that this user bot and number
of movies and this is this would be the
user profile and recommendation is based
on the basis of recommendation could
also be based on the keywords that the
person's right so this grey box says
past purchase it could be past searches
right
person could have searched a lot about
sci-fi movies or action movies or
particular products so that's why this
content-based filtering is based on
these either history of purchases or
searches this is this table is just to
show you that there is no one tailored
there is no one solution it's not there
it's not like one solution would fit for
all right so companies would use a
different and a number of different
approaches for example in the red box it
will show you that how Amazon used in
Amazon we have customers who bought
things so the recommendation interface
is based on similar items recommendation
technology is item 2 item correlation
based on purchase data or they have
email campaigns oh and amazon.com
delivery these are email again it's
based on attributes of products or
people food matters or customer comments
so companies use many different or the
second example you see that City now use
two different ones its album advisor and
my CD now which is based on
recommendation is based on similar items
or top top or popular items on the
website so the take-home message is that
there is no single solution companies
tend to use many different filtering
approaches and recommendation engines
would take into action scenarios for
different type of customers and
different type of situations in terms of
content-based filtering there are some
advantages and again these content-based
filtering is is what is analyzed based
on items based on products so no need
for data on other users so no colder
start and able to recommend users with
unique tastes so first of all because
it's based on items based on products so
a person would come to this site and
website already knows who that person is
and so know called a start and there and
it's based on that person on it so I
could be a very movie lover person and
interested in to certain movies and have
a unique taste so recommendation system
would know that and we recommend things
that a lot it's not based on an an
average person or all other people who
live in my area so it's based on my
unique taste and another advantage of
these content-based filtering is that
tables available to recommend new and
unpopular items so again it's not based
on behavior of everyone else is based on
me only limitations is that data should
be in a structured format in a
structured format it means that that
user profile that I just mentioned
previously and another limitation is
that it's unable to use quality judgment
from other users so for example if I
love Apple Apple products so
recommendation system could keep
recommending things related to Apple
product or it may be let's use Samsung
right let's say I love Samsung and
recommendation system would recommend
samsung note 7 to me right
but because because it would take into
account only me then
it wouldn't be able to take into account
that Samsung Note seven would get fired
and now so many people have issues with
that right so it would recommend that
talk to me despite the fact that that
product may not be a good so that's why
winning but it's unable to use quality
judgement okay so we got a little bit of
high level understanding of what
recommendation system is like methods in
terms of filtering based on people's
taste or based on items and we know that
companies use many different approaches
let's go through cases study an example
of how recommendation system is used in
real world in a big company like Amazon
or in other ecommerce companies
recommender systems are changing from no
what is used by a few ecommerce sites
like Amazon to serious business tools
that are really shaping the world of
e-commerce so they are not a luxury
thing anymore they are there it needed a
musting for ecommerce companies
ecommerce ecommerce is a huge sector of
industry worldwide retail e-commerce
sells will reach one point nine trillion
dollar this year so one point nine
trillion dollar it just imagine how big
these industries double-digit growth
will continue through 2020 when sells
will talk four trillion so not only it
is a big industry now but it is going to
be all more than double by 2020 and in
the figure below you'll see that some
examples that in Black Friday or Cyber
Monday sells comparing 2013 it says one
point two billion in 2013
it went up to one point five and then
one point two one place seven and not
only in the US
in China it went up from 5.77 in two
thousand thirteen to fourteen point
three billion in 2050 so ecommerce is
huge it's not only in certain countries
second market it's all over the world so
people who would be able to work in this
area would have lot of opportunities not
only in let's say North America or
Europe or Asia everywhere everywhere and
it is a growing industry now let's use
Amazon as an example of this sector
Amazon is a gold standard ecommerce it's
a pioneer company in using
recommendation system in 2015 Amazon
surpassed Walmart as the most valuable
retailer in the United States it is the
fourth most valuable public company its
revenue is one hundred and seven billion
dollar it was in 2015 and it employs 268
200 almost seventy thousand people and
this one has a way to other people a lot
of them all right it is all about online
sell right and these are people who have
knowledge of data science IT etc so huge
a huge opportunity in terms of working
in Amazon recommendation systems or
engines can offer recommendations about
collective preferences in Amazon on
Amazon website so that's the first type
of ways that recommendation system in
Amazon works and that's based on
collective preferences so let's say if
is the first time that you go to
Amazon's website it would look like this
they like to look like the figure
and and you will see that there are some
recommendations and this is based on
popular items that are satisfied some
pre specified criteria like number of
items deal in my local area so example
if I live in New York in Manhattan and
and people in my area at certain time of
year tend to look for certain items that
would be picked up by Amazon and if
Amazon doesn't know anything about me on
the first page when I go there I will
see things that are based on what people
are searching in my area or time on item
view sometimes people may by mistake
click on something and then quickly go
to another idea
so as an Amazon recommendation system
would also take into account time and
number of purchase times so these are
also additional indicators to show that
these these preferences at my local
level it could be as small as a street
level or it could be as small as people
living in my building or it could be
about people in my country so if this is
when and as I doesn't know anything
about you guys when you go there based
on collective preferences it would
recommend some stuff that would be
likely relevant to you guys in terms of
non-personalized recommendations and
sorry it was this and the words is cut
it's because sometimes I use I apologize
varies sometimes I use Windows to make
my slides and but by default I use match
so that's why you see that these words
are caught on the side it is a little
bit distracting I apologize and by
cutting out it means that in at the end
of recommendation is that properly
adjusted I apologize for that one going
back to topic non-personalized
recommendation so non-personalized is
about this it's about it's not
personalized it's about collective
preferences
so what we learned here it was that
based on my local level searches and
patterns that Amazon would dig up it
would recommend something but as person
begins to browse a few pages the engine
determines person's preferences and
leverages this information to offer
tailored recommendations so this is the
online analysis part of this
recommendation system that as a person
goes page by page and view things the DS
recommendation system would pick up
information sorts of items of known
interest with respect to users as you
can see on this top side there is a
search there is this counter campaigns
wish list cards and from all these
sources and navigation Amazon would know
that what you like and what your
preferences are if user rate something
or choose that items as a favorite items
so these are all sorts of different ways
that Amazon would pick up information
from you guys or collect information
like this is the way that the data
acquisition and in terms of once Amazon
has enough information about you guys it
would go to personalized recommendation
now recommendations you offer
recommendations based on consumer
customers previous behavior or sort of
purchases and browsing history this is
called content-based filtering right
going back to that those types of
filtering so this is the point that I
was a knows about me and based on my
previous browsing history it would
recommend things like a relevant to me
personalized recommendations you have
seen that the customers who bought
futures is found on the information page
for each items
the first one is a frequent depart
together this is things like Association
rule mining a priori for those who have
taken data science with God they know
that we really need this particular we
did a lot of example with this part a
particular algorithm and this is
something that we learn in that in that
data science batch another thing is this
is a sort of a content is collaborative
floating recommendation items frequently
purchased along with this either another
one is what other items to customers buy
after viewing this item this is more
about correlation or conditional
dependence again we will learn these
things into the science and this is a
user based collaborative filtering it
recommends items frequently purchased by
customers to purchase purchase the same
items there are also additional
recommendation on the shopping cart page
so as you can see on each page there are
recommendations and this is a high level
sort of recommendation engine that is in
Amazon there are items of known
interests and those popular items they
would fit into a matching processor and
this matching processor would pick up
popular I would fit into popular either
popular items are items satisfied that
they have satisfied some very specific
popular criteria like page view time
that people have spend on that I'll
shred exit rate then from that matching
then that similar item list is generated
and this is a associate a commonality
index to indicate their relatedness of
items and from there those similar items
is automated and by invading image by
relative importance for example this
similar item this could be if I'm a
finalist answering would be satsang work
and
notes on airport etc and then it would
go to a failing process and based on
relevance for example if I bought and
Samsung know previously and Amazon knows
that then the this waiting processor
would know that I bought note 7 so in so
a case for samsung note 7 would be of
higher rate than a case for I don't know
iPhone or it could be based on my
ratings or previous items for example if
I want to buy a computer and this
popular idea of this has Apple has
Windows whatever they did different HP
whatever different items
this rating processor would know that
migrating previously was more on better
in terms of Apple products and you would
recommend
so algorithm is very complex and it will
go through step by step to make it more
and more customized to person so this
was about a high-level understanding of
what things
how recommendation system works in
Arizona let's go quickly through a
second case study which is a Netflix
this is a video on demand company
it helps members find content to watch
and enjoy to maximize their satisfaction
and retention a huge company six point
seven eight billion dollar in 2015
eighty-six million members 50 plus
countries and so many devices and so
many many million hours a day and as you
can see in the figure at peak hour 10:00
p.m. the share of that in North America
the traffic traffic for Netflix it's in
red it's almost the same as all other
streaming videos and just look at that
gray area web browser and compare it to
Netflix so the share of web traffic is
huge for Netflix
Netflix is all about homepage homepage
is what Netflix recommends rows are
automatically coherent it means it is by
movie general action and sci-fi cetera
and by ranking and what we mean by
ranking it means that top row is the
best guess for example the first movie
that you see is what and because that
food collects information on everybody
who watches movies in household so the
first thing is the best one that would
fit everybody's demand Ernie so all
family members may like the first one
father made love and watch a lot of
movies and would be interested in second
one the other and father made Lord made
like the third one or mother likes the
fourth one etc so this is how data that
is captured to implicit and ways is used
in terms of recommendation and
recommendations are generated based on
users recent place ratings and
interactions or taste like I may watch a
lot of action movies and that's that
would be my taste or a hybrid a
combination of both I may love action
movies but recently I've seen some nice
drama so the hybrid version would take
into account both scenarios beautifully
to hit all of these this is just to show
you that Netflix uses has a lot of data
ratings popularity of movies plays
people's interest in terms of accurate
presentations and they have information
about social media like for example they
know that I have 200 fans that most of
them like action movies so all on all of
these data which is the so-called
big data is captured by Netflix so data
from all sources so when mister when we
say Big Data and this is the so-called
Big Data
if this is an example to show you that
how these captured either from so many
different places would create that these
huge path data
situations and this is just to show you
that Netflix isn't a number of open
source offers at the back end things now
part a to a do to my sickle to live this
is a sort of technologies that that it's
being used in Netflix for example if
you're interested in terms of potato I
know that big data with diluted Apache
are being offered that simple learn and
for any of you who are interested in any
of these technologies I think there is a
batch there is a course for these in
simpler there are many different
computation layers is here on the top
and data is with big data and it's just
anything I do it's process and queries
to hive and then there are all flowing a
storage area which is a which is the
area that makes its liable connected to
the computer then we have near lines
layer computation layer and online so
this is like is just to show you that
there is very very complex processes
involved in this recommendation engine
technology at Netflix in general so for
people who are interested in different
parts of the technology there are
different courses to take and different
opportunities are being offered and this
is from algorithmically speaking on the
top figure you see that a simple way to
say that how business is in essence is
that you have thousands of possible
movies but at the end when you turn on
your TV
you'll see
10 to 40 rolls and these are the best
things for you how it works
in a simplified manner is that it
involves predicting personalized rating
again I forgot to put the star there but
for those of you who had partaken
datacenter or will be taking this as we
are we'll go through these predicting
the practices recreations disorder there
are a simple way of predicting things so
first there is a prediction involved in
personalization ranking and at the end
this is personalized homepage so a very
simple administration of what this
business is all about in three steps in
terms of algorithms that are is being
used in Netflix there are they have
three types of main algorithms there is
your soup Boltzmann machines this sv you
don't need to and you can get more
information about this algorithm is not
of the interest of this webinar but this
is just to show you that they use
different algorithms and the second
algorithm is actually if you google it
you will see that there is a nicer story
about that that as we did was was built
by a team of data scientists in 2009 and
there was a prize of $1,000,000 so it
was a sort of competition and a team of
data scientists develop that algorithm
for next week's Netflix use many
different methods unsupervised methods
like costing algorithm and supervised
classification again for data Sciences
students you know that we go through
unsupervised and supervised algorithms
and and methods like linear regression
and logistic regression so you see that
how these methods are used in day to day
work in Quebec companies like Netflix
and for those of you again roll enrolled
in data science you know that there is a
step by step
horses and this is from Netflix ersite
how they develop technology they are a
data-driven organization and they called
it cuz consumer data science so they
call these culture and consumer data
science and the main goal of these
consumer data science approach is to
innovate for members effectively so they
come up with initial hypothesis so for
those of you who know I thought this is
testing and data science we learned
about hypothesis testing it's about
coming up with an idea that for example
a certain algorithm would increase
number of customers or satisfaction then
there is this development and
independent testing and testing and
choosing a sample of because customers
and testing these hypotheses are there
so these are the things that we'll learn
our data science with or and you see
that how they are being used in Netflix
in terms of where what is next big
things that you guys could explain it
personalized learning to manage context
awareness context awareness is what time
of year it is what mood I am in and this
is about contextual information for
example if I am in a trip to India I'm I
like different movies that if I am
sitting in my home in Colorado near for
Toronto more knowledge about coolest art
about predicting people if we don't have
enough information about and this is
what it means by cold I said these are
future direction that they the science
going especially ethnic companies like
Netflix or Amazon and social
recommendations these are the big four
big areas of data science and there are
huge opportunities in terms of growth
so lessons learned recommendation system
enable businesses and coins to find
things that are interesting never done
instead of choice it helps people
businesses to recommend things that are
of interest additional and unique
personalized services for the customers
our customization is by client and user
and and it would enhance trust and
customer loyalty and current companies
obtain more knowledge about customers
and can use them to make them more
satisfied and increase the engagement
and and it's an effective solution for
long term and long term are those
products that are at the end and I know
that popular so we are almost at the end
we started a little bit late but we have
is so a few and I know that I went quick
I wanted to provide you with as much
information as possible in this
presentation I believe it would be
available on demand so if I went quick
it just meant to provide you with as
much information as you need so at this
point I guess you scare this Richard in
the back I say I hide in the back for
most of this which I did a couple we
have a number of questions coming in but
before we start drilling the questions
I'm going to take over the screen
because we do run a poll so it's always
important part of our setup so I'm going
to take over the screen while we do the
Q&A and while we're doing the Q&A we
have a number of questions coming in one
of the big ones is is there a
comprehensive learning program offered
and specifically and simply learn and I
know we have the master's programs can
you talk a little bit about that like
with that what kind of programs they
have exactly so as I was explaining and
throughout the presentation I try to
link that what's going on
in real world and in these huge
companies with what we learn at a
particular data science and I mentioned
about different technologies for example
I mentioned about different technologies
that is being used in Netflix now
superwoman has a master's program in
data science that in that program I
believe that all the data science is
part of it so data science would be
foundation to other presently I mention
about these prediction about correlation
these are the things that the students
will learn in that data science and on
top of that there are additional batches
in that master's program that if it will
learn about Big Data I mention about Big
Data but all those sources of
information so those are so given that
huge databases people need to use
certain technologies things like I do or
a stuff like that so as part of that
massive program people would also be
able to learn about those technologies
about those tools so masters a program
in data science is one that could enable
students to learn everything that they
just explained okay excellent
and then we do have a couple questions
and you mentioned it a little bit about
and I'll go ahead and fill this one
first again is this recording is this
being recorded and is this available
afterward the answer is yes they do
record all our sessions that bakit
simply learned and it takes up to 24
hours for them to post it because they
have to physically check and make sure
something doesn't get messed up you know
no one a POLST an empty file and then if
you go to simply learn and you go under
the support just click on the support
and request you can just request it and
they'll send you the link for that for
the session today just mention today's
session and they'll send you that
information we do have a lot of
questions coming in here so let me see
how many we can get through before we'll
go a little bit over and then we are at
the end of the hour one of the people
asks what would you suggest
they're not technical so this is
somebody who doesn't want to learn the
programming or they do file system for
big data but they're coming from the
management site project manager who
wants to understand the analytics a
little bit more so they know what
they're talking about when they talk to
somebody in their company there are many
many many opportunities in terms of
non-technical itself a project manager
may need to know about a little bit of
technical like for example data science
what are we go through some technical
information but those technical
information are needed for project
manager because a project manager would
need to know about estimated time how
much effort is needed and having strong
at least some technical information
could help and project management and
some better identifying risk estimated
timelines and stuff like that so I
encourage you in particular to have a
tool for those who are interested more
on business site to have at least some I
mean the project manager and manage a
business manager doesn't need to create
an algorithm or wrong correlational
analysis but a project manager a manager
may need to know that the type of
business that they are they would need
certain technologies or certain
approaches and estimated time so that's
it so having that minimal knowledge is
needed I know that a simple let me have
so many project management courses as
well so those are the parts that are
business-related so there are courses
that are being offered specifically for
business oil I encourage people that are
in business so at least have some
technical knowledge now another thing
another area that people could get
involved is about understanding
marketing part of it so marketing needs
to understand lawyers in terms of
helping technical people to build
I mentioned about these models for
example people live in New York 20 to 25
year old versus people live in Paris 40
to 45 so these are the sort of knowledge
that are needed in order to build these
models but they don't necessarily come
from technical people so marketing and
those sort of approaches are also needed
if a person wants to work in these sort
of companies they certainly need people
with that would have that sort of
knowledge and bringing that sort of it
skills but again they may have they may
need some basic technical information as
well in terms of opportunities in terms
of what what is possible and it's
feasible as well so hopefully I oh
absolutely
no I thought you answered it quite well
it is it is a complicated subject
because when you certainly can go on to
simply learn and go under one of the
forums and ask for a more detailed
specific to your situation in what
industry you're in if we had time I'd
ask you to ask that question again and
fill that in but we do have a couple
more questions I'm hoping we can get to
before we hit the end of our period we
have a question that came in let's see
where was it what languages are used for
data science from I'm gonna mispronounce
this name such in write so many
different languages depending on which
area you know and what companies are a
person works but most popular in data
science in business analytics two of the
most popular ones are that are used for
analytic purposes are are and SAS these
are languages that are very popular or a
little bit more popular because it's a
free and it's open source software SAS
is very expensive but some companies use
SAS as well those who learn or would
have a little bit of
and it would make it easier for them to
learn sass and vice-versa so these are
the top two most popular languages in
terms of Business Analytics and of
course we have languages for big data
that that are based on the big data but
in terms of typical business analytic
and data science our asses are their
standards yes excellent let's see let me
go let's go ahead and do one more
question I got kind of a long one so
take me a few minutes to put it together
from Alejandro he's asking about in
Amazon when they do the Amazon
recommendations and they recommend two
different regular gardania's hoops
I think splashing around two different
recommendations could you please clarify
the difference between collaborative
item based filtering content-based
filtering and how do they get I don't
know I'm not doing a good job going
through this my apologies I guess he
wants to know is you know how do they do
recommendations and getting multiple
items so they're not related like toilet
paper versus iPhone that was example he
gave how do those how does Amazon deal
with that having multiple melding all
their different recommendations together
so the difference between the two main
types of filtering is that one of them
is based on person for example if I if I
go to Amazon and buy a bunch of stuff
house cleaning toilet paper and stuff
like that to Rotom the first couple of
time years I may buy some irrelevant
stuff so that's why Amazon may use item
try them
filtering approach may use that but
eventually through our time there would
be a pattern like it's not like always
and always go to Amazon I'm fighting
strangle me I would use Amazon for
certain things
so to road time and I will learn that
yet today I bought an iPhone and a
toilet paper but it was because it was
just today that they ran out of and
Walmart I couldn't go to Walmart and buy
that so I was on Amazon and I bought it
but you are trying it would learn about
that but mean more meantime I came to
item correlation could also help address
that for example those who bought iPhone
are not likely isn't not associated with
buying buying toilet paper is associated
with buying cases with buying additional
T so if there is enough knowledge about
the person to reduce notes and that well
paper in Davis s is called noise it's
irrelevant data so there are ways to
understand how good data is and to and
to exclude noise from data now
if Amazon has enough knowledge about my
behavior it would reduce that noise and
it would take into I can correlate the
other stuff but if not then it would go
to item 2 item copulation and it would
for example in two boxes it will show
you one at what other people who box
iPhones but as well and another one
would be both of people who bought
really paper what else stated by so you
see there may that's why they are using
hybrid and many different races because
in real world it's not as simple as
people's behavior would be the same so
there are plenty a B C and E's for every
scenario and this is what algorithms
come to to work excellent do you have
time Simon to hang around for about two
or three more questions of course sure
ok excellent one of the big questions
that comes up a lot that
I hear because it's like quite the
catchphrase is AI artificial
intelligence
how does data science relate to AI is a
relationship between artificial
intelligence and data science for sure
is all about it's it's a data science
the foundation of that and it's about
learning and and learning from behavior
and it is actually a big area that is
going to be used in businesses so David
earlier he related ok excellent and I
actually was working with a group
earlier that had spark on the big data
Hadoop and part of it was the machine
learning was part of the AI they were
working on so that those my experiences
it's exciting stuff yeah let's see we
have a get a couple more in there how
does run recommendation engine at scale
so how do you how does this scale up and
we doing the recommendation engine how
do they get that scaled up for this
massive amount of data
I mean Amazon has what am i interested
in three steps are flying an airline and
online in two different steps it's a
huge huge huge I cannot really explain
it in one or two but and that is like as
I mentioned about offline you're not an
online they that is basically a scale
that and and also in terms of technology
they're using many different
technologies like you mentioned I what I
do and Big Data technologies that they
have attempted of this large amounts of
data and I know that we have a sink - as
simple as part of these masters in data
science that we talk about these these
technical issues X
yeah this stuff's always I get excited
about this stuff so I love being in the
back on these webinars let's just sneak
a couple more in there because we still
have people coming in with questions can
you explain the difference where's the
line between data science and statistics
and how do they overlap they do overlap
a lot data science for a person who
wants to work in data science and a
person would need to have knowledge of
programming knowledge of technology so
technology is part of it how to work for
example with all stars etc and another
part of it is the statistics is about
for example a mention of a correlation
evolved building models discussed during
classification these are statistical
approaches it's requirement it's a must
for a data science person it's a must to
know statistics as well and that's what
a data science with R is about in big
part of that data science with r we go
to statistics courses and we used
software to apply those statistical
concepts they are interdependent
excellent and then one last question
we're going to use the then we're gonna
wrap it up do you have any books you can
recommend or references that somebody
who wants to gain a bit more knowledge
in data science I don't have heard of it
but if you guys classes and at each
class and for each topic I usually
recommend some books but unfortunately I
was not expecting this question but if
if if anybody wants that if you go to
simple learn
community for whom we can be in touch
there I can put some information into it
some answers to these differences there
are a bunch of great books that people
or books online resources that people
can use
so maybe that's a good way to for us to
communicate excellent well thank you
Simon and you know it's a good reference
that was Rajesh who was asking about
that and I hope I said the name correct
we do have the forum so if you have more
questions or anything like that you go
to simply learn and then go into the
community and there is an open community
there you can ask questions and then if
you are registered there's also the
simply learn simply talk for those
people who are registered students thank
you very much Simon for being here today
and taking your time to do this webinar
with us thank you so much I really
appreciate everyone's attendance and
your questions and Richard thanks for
your support and and everything
excellent I'm gonna go ahead and close
the session and I wish everybody happy
learning I had by the way sergeant is
thanks Simon
yep thanks everyone Alejandro Alejandro
have I said that right there we go
everybody have a I wish you a wonderful
evening afternoon or morning we look
forward to seeing you in the classes and
take care and happy learning
you